hey everyone
welcome to the direct path number 12.
if you haven't yet check out the other
videos in this series
what we're doing in the direct path
series is
we are both recognizing
the non-dual wisdom which is that
we are already it there is nothing to
seek
the diamond necklace is already around
each of our necks
at the same time that we recognize the
dualistic concession
which is that there is a mountain
there is something to seek something to
find and someone to become enlightened
and that process
eradicates suffering it eradicates
the contracted egoic energy
that's trying to self-deal greedy
achieving
conspicuous consumption and other
materialistic
goals in maya in the intoxication
and in doing so it liberates us that
enlightenment liberates us it
enables us to truly recognize the
diamond necklace around our neck to
truly become
free and wise and unconditionally loving
and peaceful equanimous
and we point to
the one end at the top of the mountain
from
all of these different faces from all of
these different
paths from all these different signposts
in order to provide a really robust
comprehensive lattice work around
non-duality and the dualistic concession
around enlightenment and that way the
audience the viewers you guys get to
pick
which signposts which which concepts
which paths which faces
resonate with you in your own process of
both
god realization as well as god
actualization which is
the simultaneity of going inward and
recognizing the absolute ineffable that
we all already are
as well as the expression outward to be
of the absolute
highest morality to weave
like the tantric tradition your profound
realizations
into the social fabric into your daily
activities
like ramana maharshi said with sahaja
samadhi
or like we've been saying with the
goldilocks zone
just like planet earth is in the
goldilocks zone
around the star is the same thing with
humans being in the goldilocks zone
with their enlightened realizations
so in this one we're going to explore
the
fascinating approach that really worked
for me
and will likely work for a good amount
of people because it's very logical
and it's very scientific and
because of that it becomes more
objective it becomes easier for people
to
buy into and then
they can take the intuitive leap after
this very
objective scientific process
so let's go ahead and start that off
with physicalism oneness
so this is what we mean by the very
objective very scientific
so here we are taking 20 000 breaths a
day
and each one of these breaths depends on
the photosynthesis that's happening from
the phytoplankton in the trees
so 70 percent of the planetary
oxygenation comes from phytoplankton and
about 30 percent of it comes from trees
so each one of these 20 000 breaths that
each of us take
per day is coming from photosynthesis
planetary oxygenation and so you would
ask yourself
when does the oxygen molecule that i
inhale that then oxygenates my body
when does that process
become me when does my oxygen molecule
become me
when does the oxygenation of my body
become
me what about when i exhale the co2
when i exhale that when does that not
become me
when it leaves my lungs
and you can ask a very similar question
with the 1000 plus bacteria species that
are in your gut
so the multi-billion
year bacteria planetarily
ended up finding a home in the gi
tract of mammals aka the human animal
now
and there's an incredible symbiotic
relationship that's developed where each
one of those 1000 plus bacteria species
in our gut has 2 000 plus gene
expressions
so that means there are 2 million plus
total gene expressions that we are in
symbiosis with
in just the bacteria species in our gut
and so you might ask yourself well if
there's 20 000 plus
human gene expression so there's a
hundred times
more bacterial gene expressions you
might ask yourself something like
well where does the line begin to what
this atlas
unit is and where the bacteria is
are they one thing they're one thing you
can't draw a line between the 1000
bacteria in a symbiotic relationship
the 1000 species of bacteria in a
symbiotic relationship
with you you can't draw that line
another way to point this out is the
same hydrological cycle that dinosaurs
were drinking from 66 million years ago
is what we drink from today it's not
like
the planetary hydrological cycle has
changed
it's not like over the last four billion
years of planetary evolution that
somehow the hydrological cycle got
switched out for a new hydrological
cycle
it doesn't it's not what happens it's
all the same planetary hydrological
cycle over billions of years
so you're drinking what has been drank
by dinosaurs what has come
out from our urination is
constantly being recycled as a planet
into our filtered water that we then
drink again
so where exactly is the line of
separation between
you and your water so is this water
me right now okay how about now
what about now
so is it me now that i've swallowed it
was it me when it was just in my mouth
is it now me as it's going down my
esophagus
when is it me and so
these are the questions you might ask
yourself
is where is the line of separation
between you and the air
and the water and the food you eat and
the microbes that live inside of you
where is the line of separation
because once you recognize that you
can't find a line of separation
that's when you recognize physicalism
oneness you recognize that oh
all eight billion humans on the planet
are
in a union a yoga
henosis mysticism we're in one
union with the planet we survive
on the planet providing us with the air
the water the food
so what sustains us is planet earth
it's what we share so it's the
physicalism oneness
that we recognize
that's a really profound leap if you can
scientifically
objectively recognize this leap to
physicalism oneness from being an egoic
contracted separate entity
if you can recognize it simply from the
breaths of air from the drinks of water
from the food you eat and from your
relationship with your microbes
that is profoundly advancing and
augmenting
in one state of awareness you are
piercing
the veil more and more by just getting
to physicalism oneness
now
next up is this intuitive leap to
awareness so once you get to physicalism
oneness
you will also recognize things like okay
well if planet earth
truly sustains all of us to that degree
where there's no separation
then let me look at the eyes of another
subject
okay now when you look at the eyes of
another subject what will happen is
you will look and you will see that
the pupil itself is
what is shared that awareness or
consciousness is shared we all come from
the same
source whereas the iris
is the unique coloration of each
individual expression
from that source so each one of us has
the diamond necklace that is already
around our neck
but each one of those jewels is unique
so the diamond or the jewel is the pupil
whereas the uniqueness of it
is the iris and that's what refracts
the source light as the artistic
expression
out into the dreamed creation design
that this is
and so you begin making these intuitive
leaps you end up relaxing more and more
back into your awareness
because you recognize things like the
very childlike analogies
where you do things like
recognize that awareness is pure
bare and empty and you make this
juxtaposition
and then you recognize that that
awareness is being
colored by experience and in this case
it's being colored by
words and in this case it's being
colored by art and so you recognize that
awareness
is shared this is what is shared this is
the pupil
and this is the iris this is what
is being colored as the experience onto
the pure
bear empty awareness that is shared this
is
god which we all are god
is the seer as ramana maharshi said
that is being colored eternally by
experience and so you can think about
this
as the sky that is being
colored by the clouds you can think
about this
as the ocean that is being colored
by unique waves here the waves
are words and here the waves are art
here the sky is being colored by the
clouds of
words and here the skies being colored
by the clouds of
art also with technology this can be
thought of as your phone screen
when it's locked and it's dark and black
and then this is when you unlock your
phone screen and you begin browsing
the internet or social apps and you get
words and you get images
so we're undergoing this process of
eternally being modulated
in these dream creation designs and it's
a very
intuitive leap to awareness it's a
relaxing back
and back into this ever expanding
state like rumi said where you become
more aware of awareness itself
you become aware that god is the seer
you become aware that reality is
fundamentally consciousness based
because you can't experience a simulated
dream without an observer
and you can't experience a video game
without a player
when you go to sleep at night you sleep
for a third of your life
and it's fascinating because all of
these clues are right under our nose and
they're very
childlike and they're very explained
like i'm five
you go and you simulate this dream
you simulate out this dreamed reality
where you immerse yourself
into the perspective of an observer or a
witness in the first person perspective
and you're walking around in this dream
simulation and experiencing it
and you never once think to yourself
that oh that house that i just passed
by in the dream simulation well it's
probably still there although i'm not
even
observing it anymore of course it's not
and that's the thing to the people that
are currently living in other countries
around the world they're
experiencing their own formulations
their own simulations
of those areas of the world that they're
in
and right now this atlas unit
is also in the process of forming a
dreamed simulation
around what california and los angeles
and this recording studio is
whereas they are not doing that unless
they undergo the process of the
all-inclusive awareness which is a
higher state of god realization
where it would be like they would be
also simultaneously
taking in their worldview and simulated
dream perspective
while they also taken the perspective
that this atlas unit is currently having
it's a higher level of god realization
and all-inclusive awareness
across all 8 billion of the dream
simulations that are happening here at
the same time
and you can't have a video game without
a player either anybody that's played a
video game will tell you that while
you're playing the game
you immerse yourself into the character
in the first person or the third person
perspective in the video game
and what happens is that you can't play
the game without a character
it doesn't make sense you can't play the
game without a character
so we have to use consciousness we have
to use awareness we have to use an agent
of experience an
agent of a witness or an observer to
immerse ourselves
into these dreamed landscapes into these
simulated worlds
and then which are just the modulation
fluctuation of energy as quantum
mechanics is proving
and so there's an infinite amount of
ways for
the energy to be modulated just like
there's an infinite amount of ways for
music to be modulated just like there's
an infinite amount of ways
for you to take all of the different
colors in the color wheel or in a color
palette
and combine them to make unique
expressions in these
realities and that's why science
is recognizing cyclic cosmology
as we have sir roger penrose who won the
nobel prize in physics in 2020 has a
theory of cyclic cosmology
and that's why we have the multiverse
which means many songs
so it's not just the universe the one
song and it's not just the observers
what's observable
but it's the many songs because
symphonies don't play one song
symphonies play songs and songs
and songs and realities and realities
and realities those are the same things
song is a reality a song is a dream
a song is a modulation of musical notes
and silence
just like us a song is also a modulation
of energetics that underlie all matter
at a quantum mechanical level
so awareness is eternally being colored
by experience
and the way to recognize that again is
to locate the sense of i
ask yourself what is i
and take your time with that what is i
what is i
and then you recognize that the i
is the observer the i is the witness the
i
is the consciousness is the awareness
and then you focus and investigate that
directly so
investigate awareness directly
consciousness directly the witness the
observer directly
use these very friendly analogies where
you recognize that witness
observer that you're investigating as
the pure bear empty awareness that is
eternally being colored
by the experience in these dream
creation designs
and then you have things like the
hawthorne effect which help a lot
which has a lot to do with
accountability and observation
because when you are being observed by
yourself
by god because it's just another
perspective of god observing god itself
as you so in this case you as the
audience are watching
this unit atlas and so this unit
has a higher likelihood of being
a god realized mirror and so when you're
alone and there's no observation when
there's no hawthorne effect
you have a higher likelihood to do
something that is malevolent you have a
higher likelihood to do something that
is egoic
or driven by self-dealing and that's why
it's always beneficial
to have something like high levels of
accountability
and that's why people have
accountability partners when they go and
work out that's why they have
accountability partners when they go on
fasts
that's why they have accountability
partners with work
and that's why as an entrepreneur as
somebody especially that runs their own
llc what happens is that
it becomes really important for them to
have the self-discipline to motivate
themselves to execute because nobody
else is holding them accountable
that's why partnerships can be
beneficial because you hold each other
accountable to execute
and so we have to take this intuitive
leap to awareness but a big part of that
comes with
understanding that finity form and time
are temporary and not
eternal truth and so i've become
obsessed with time to the degree at
which
i have purchased and will bring around
this clock with me everywhere now
because what i'm trying to do is i'm
trying to get people to wake up to the
fact that
we put these
squibbles on
the interface of a circle
and these symbols are now like a
cultural
dogma of hypnosis which say that the
earth
spinning on its axis and orbiting the
star
must be labeled this way and that's
truth
it's not it's only our temporary
finite expression of what time is
it's the way that we labeled it you can
replace
any of these squiggles any of these
symbols
with other symbols and you can have that
be operating for millennia and then have
people say that that is what time is
and so once you are able to understand
the illusion of time
it helps you understand our eternity
our infinitude and how this is just one
finite expression of that this is just
one
finite form this is one song
this is one modulation at the quantum
mechanical level of the energy
this is one modulation of the music of
the energy
of the artistic palette
and this is what science technology and
engineering will probe soon because it's
becoming more and more clear
to us that we're planting flags
that spirituality has known for a really
long time
beyond the edge of what science is
proving
and then science slowly works its way
via hypotheses
and the scientific method towards those
flags and just proves what spirituality
already knows
so science will be able to validate
eternity it'll be able to validate
infinity
very soon and it's exciting because
it will wake us all up to the
macro level nature of reality
that is not constricted to the finite
egoic
expression that is what the cultural
dogma in hypnosis has been beating like
a drum
into people's psyche upon their infancy
and so when you have an infant that
never gets that cultural dogma and
hypnosis
beat into them at a young age what
happens is they
retain their infinitude while they also
retain
their unique creative artistic
expression
and that's ultimately the optimal
education the optimal education like
we're working on in our vr pedagogy
and animated series and all our content
is that
the child from infancy retains the
highest
god realization inward expression of
infinitude
while it simultaneously expresses
outward from the absolute highest
morality
so it never undergoes the process of the
parable of the prodigal son when it goes
outward as an egoic separate entity and
hits a breaking point and then has to
turn
inward and because that breaking point
is also ecologically disastrous for our
planet
as well and that's what prevents
the birthing of new infants
coming in portaling into the world and
being able to
experience it and have a blast in this
dream
because we are being extremely ignorant
with what sustains us aka
the planetary ecology
and then you recognize that physicalism
and awareness are one so once you've
taken
the leap to physicalism oneness and then
you've taken the leap
to awareness itself then you recognize
that awareness and physicalism are
one that there is not two and this is
what non-duality means this is what the
synthesis of science and spirituality is
the synthesis of physicalism and
consciousness
observers need physicalism creation
designs
we've talked about this earlier that the
video game needs the video game
character that the dream needs the
observer
the observer needs the physicalism
creation design
just like the witness needs the dreamed
landscape and so the witness in the
dream landscape
are one they're not two and so we
recognize that our awareness is shared
from the same source
when you recognize that the awareness is
shared from the same source
that gives you a
awareness that we share our being which
is what love is
love is the awareness that we share our
being and when you get to that
point then you never commit malevolence
on another because you recognize that
it's just an
expression of infinity that is actually
you
i'm you you're me we're the same
infiniti that is expressing itself so i
would never hurt you
and you begin engaging with the world
from peace joy and love
so i am peace joy and love that is
engaging with the world
i am not seeking peace joy and love i'm
not trying to extract
peace joy and love from the world
and that's a massive shift because what
happens is people say that
i'm going to find a significant other
that's going to bring me peace joy and
love i'm going to
find a materialistic possession or money
that's going to bring me peace joy and
love
no you are inherently peace joy and love
that is then engaging with the world
from that perspective
that's a profound shift and the only
problem is our resistance to what is
all suffering is resistance
even when you're feeling something that
arises that is maybe not the peace joy
in love
and it's for a moment some sadness or
some depression as soon as you love
yourself and accept yourself exactly the
way it is that you keep
riding on the crest instead of trying to
fight it
what happens is boom it's right back to
peace
love and joy because you recognize how
it brings a smile to your face that you
recognize yourself as the sky that felt
the temporary
cloud of a moment of sadness
because you have a meta awareness you
have a metacognition a meta
consciousness
on the scenarios that are happening at
hand
and so you recognize yourself as
peaceful unconditionally fulfilled
presence awareness
this is already unconditionally
fulfilled
it is infinity expressing itself it's
infinity exploring
unboundedness you can't finish exploring
something that's unbounded
we'll never come to the end of all
experience
we'll never come to the end of all
phenomenology we will never come to the
end
and that's the beauty of this we will
always be playing leela
always be the the divine play the cosmic
play that is happening
where we immerse ourselves into these
dream creation designs
and we veil ourself we forget what we
are
and then we turn back and we pierce the
veil we recognize our own true nature
and so in essence physicalism oneness
at first must be recognized we have to
recognize the physicalism oneness
the breaths of air the water the food
the microbes
then it's recognized as simply a finite
expression so once you recognize the
physicalism oneness
then you recognize well this is just a
finite expression this is one
dreamed creation design in order to take
the intuitive leap towards infinity
which is all of the eternal dream
creation designs
that's a profound shift and you
recognize that that awareness is eternal
and it's being colored by the experience
of the creation designs
and so afterward one can integrate the
energy that's modulating as
matter as inseparable from consciousness
and that's the direct path number 12.
so again getting to a point of
physicalism oneness
which is the contracted egoic finite
energy
that relaxes into the oceanic-ness
then the intuitive leap to awareness
is when the oceanic-ness recognizes
its eternity its infinitude that is
being colored by the waves
of experience
and this really helps by locating the
sense of
i what is the i meditate on that more
and focus and investigate that directly
and then it's the recognition that
physicalism and awareness are one
that the ocean and the wave are not two
separate things but they are one thing
and that is infinity expressing itself
and this is just
one version of that
and this part's so important to engage
with the world
from peace joy and love and not trying
to extract
peace joy and love from the world and
that was a profound teaching of rupert
spyra that
really augmented me a lot as well
all right that's it direct path number
12. hope this brought you massive value
i would love to hear from you in the
comments below let me know where you're
at
also like the video if it brought you
value subscribe if you haven't
also share the video with people that
you know this would profoundly influence
and also feel free to join the
membership
on the channel we have exclusive
benefits and perks and all of the
finances
end up going directly to the
actualization
of all of the dreams and projects that
we have going on here
and that's all
recognize the diamond necklace that is
already around your neck
go all the way inward to the god
realization to the absolute to the
ineffable
and then have that catalyze the wu way
effortless action
of your unique artistic expression to
architect the more abundant and
prosperous future that we all know
is possible adore you infinitely
thank you
you